وقبل الحصاد كنت قد اجريت مقابله مع وزيره
الخارجيه سلوفينيه ثانيه فايون من ميونخ
وسالتها اولا عن تقييمها للانجازات
والاخفاقات خلال حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
مساء الخير وشكرا على استضافه اليوم لقد
كانت كان يوما طويلا ومكثفا في مؤتمر
ميونخ للامن لكن بالتاكيد الموضوع على
اساس الذي ناقشناه كان الاعتداء الروسي
الظالم على اوكرانيا ستمر ذكرى الاولى وما
نواجهه اكثر من 7000 مدنيه
هنا تحت يدمرات وايضا هذه الامور مستمره
ما نحاول ان نقوم به في سلوفينيا نحن نحقق
بدلي ما بوسعنا من اجل مساعدتي اوكرانيا
من اجل الدفاع عن سيادتها واراضيها
وسنستمر بالقيامه بذلك كلما كان الامر
ضروريا علينا ايضا ان نبذل قصار جهدنا من
اجل ان نجد طريقه لانهاء هذه الحرب ونبدا
بمفاوضات نحو تحقيق السلام بالتالي العالم
بعد الرابع والعشرين فبراير قد تغير بشكل
كبير اذ نعيش في اوقات تفتقر الى الامن
والاطمئنان وبالتاكيد نحتاج الى كل
شركائنا في العالم من اجل ان نعمل سويه
وفي نفس الوقت ان لا ننسى الصراعات الاخرى
في العالم وهي ايضا هذه الرساله التي
خرجنا بها من مؤتمر اليوم
تحدثت عن امكانيه الذهاب للتفاوض والانهاء
لهذه الحرب من خلال بوابه الحوار هل لمست
داخل اروقات مؤتمر ميونخ حديثا او نافذه
تفتح من قبل مجموعه الدول الغربيه المعنيه
بملف الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا بهذا
الاتجاه
ونحن جميعا نريد ان نرى نهايه الحرب في
اوكرانيا لكن علينا ان نكون في نفس الوقت
مهيئين لفكره ان هذه الحرب قد تطول اكثر
مما توقنه علينا ان نكون موحدين ورساله
اليوم ايضا كانت تؤكد على هذا الموعد نبقى
موحدين في الدفاع عن اوكرانيا ومساعدتها
في هذه المعركه اليوم سمعنا ايضا انما
يقوم به نظام الروسي ايضا هو هنالك جرائم
ترتكب ضد الانسانيه هذه امور لا يجب ان
نسكت عليها علينا ان نقوم بشيء بكل ما
نستطيع من اجل ان نحافظ ندافع عن قيمنا
وعن النظام الدولي وايضا هذا الصراع
الموجود في القاره الاوروبيه بالتاكيد هو
يؤثر على العالم باكمله وقد ذكرت هذا
الامر في السابق ايضا علينا ان نفهم بعضنا
البعض ونتحدث مع بعضنا البعض واعلينا ان
نتعامل مع كل العالميه المحيطه بناء لكن
هنالك شيء مؤكد بالنسبه نحن نقوم بكل ما
بوسعنا من اجل احترام القانون الدولي وان
لا نهدد امن العالم على ذكر الحديث الواحد
والمشترك او الموحد للشركاء الدوليين خاصه
فيما يتعلق بالحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا
كان هناك تباين في مواقف خاصه بالنسبه
لسقف العالي الذي يطالب به الرئيس
الاوكراني زيلينسكي بخصوص التزويد
بالاسلحه ما مستوى التباين وجهه نظرك
وتاثيره على مجريات الحرب
مرت سنه واحده على الحرب
اوروبا تقف موحده وايضا شركائنا من حلف
شمال الاطلسي ايضا الرساله قويه وموحده
نعم انت محقه في قولك اننا نريد ان نرى
السلام ونريد ان نرى بدايه لمفاوضات نحو
السلام لكن ما باستطاعتي ان اقوله فقط انه
لدينا ربما الطرق مختلفه حول كيفيه حمايه
النظام العالمي وكيفيه تامين مستقبلنا
وكيف ان نضع مواطنين في قلبي وفي جوهر
الصناعه سياسه وايضا ما هو ما هو ايضا
قتالنا الدولي ضد تغير المناخي ايضا هنالك
الكثير من المنظمات مثل منظمات الامم
المتحده التي باستطاعتنا ان خلالها ان نجد
حلولا والان نحن نح ان نكون عضوا في مجلس
الامن في الامم المتحده باستطاعتي ان اقول
صدقا انه بوجود هذه الامكانيه امكانيه
واهميه التاكيد على اهميه السلام والامن
وان نستمع لبعضنا البعض وان نطرح
اهتماماتنا ومصالحاتنا ونبدا بالحديث عن
المفاوضات اعتقد ان دور هذا يمكن ان تطلع
فيه سلوفينيا وهنا اريد ان اسالك انت في
هذه المشاركه هل يعني سمعت مثل سمعتي عن
حديث التخطيط عن توحيد الصفوف يعني مناقشه
كيف يمكن ردم هذه التباينات بين مواقف
الدول خاصه بخصوص الحرب الروسيه هل سمعتي
حديث موازي عن التخطيط
يعني بوابه سلام او مسار سلام او تفاوض
خاصه مع طرح صيني من قبل وزير الخارجيه
بهذا
الشان
شهد دوليه بامكانه ان ياتي بحل سلمي او ان
ياتي الاطراف المتعدده الى طاوله
المفاوضات هو امر نرحب به نحن لن نقوم باي
شيء يصعد من الحرب بالتالي ما اعتقده صدقا
لانه علينا ان نعمل سويه
باطراف متعدده وعن طريق جهات ومنظمات
مختلفه من اجل حمايه القانون الدولي
واحترامي لم اسمع ان ينقسام هنا في
النقاشات وخاصه عندما يتعلق الامر بالحرب
في اوكرانيا لكنني سمعت كيف مدى حاجتنا
للاستماع لبعضنا البعض وايضا كما ان اهميه
انه
احتضان الغربي لقضايا اخرى المتعلقه
بالصراع والامن الطاقوي وايضا بامور
الهجره
والتغيرات المناخيه لكل هذه القضايا نحتاج
الى بعضنا البعض بالتالي فان حل صراع واحد
لن يؤمن مستقبلنا وكيف يمكن جعل العالم
اكثر امنا خاصه مع يعني وجهه ما نشاهده
مثلا على
مستوى عدم فعاليه او عدم الذهاب الى مزيد
من مسارات الحوار او فتح نوافذ للحوار
بامكاننا ان نجعل العلماء اكثر امنا علينا
ان نعمل سويه ليس فقط نحن صناع اساسا لكن
المجتمعات المدنيه اصحاب المشاريع وايضا
الحصول والمتوصل الى
التوافقات علينا ان يكون هنالك جهد دولي
للتعامل مع اي صراع يندلع مثلا علينا ان
نفهم ان دور القانون والقانون الدولي
والنظام الدولي يجب ان يكون في عقولنا
وقلوبنا عندما نفكر برسم سياسه معينه
واتخاذ قرار معين ما يحصل في الصين وما
يحصل في افريقيا وما يحصل في امريكا
اللاتينيه وايضا امور التغيرات المناخيه
هذه تؤثر علينا جميعا علينا ان نعترف بهذا
الامر وبالتالي
لهذا ان مثل هذا المؤتمر مؤتمر ميونخ ياتي
بالاطراف المختلفه وهذا امر مهم جدا من
اجل بناء هذا التفاهم المشترك وهو امر
ضروري اكثر من اي وقت مضى شكرا لك يا سيده
تانيه وزيره خارجيه السلوفينيا حدثنا من
ميونخ شكرا على المشاركه معنا